hippos are pretty cute with their rotund
bodies short stubby legs and sly smirks
ah
but if you happen upon one beware
they're one of the most fearsome animals
in the world hippos may seem harmless
but they're far from it in africa hippos
kill around 500 people a year making
them twice as deadly as lions
they have a bite force of up to 12
600 kilopascals a hippo could sever a
person in two as easily as we can snap a
chocolate bar
so what makes these seemingly gentle
giants so deadly
what do they eat
and why is their poop so destructive
the hippopotamus is the second largest
land animal on earth following the
elephant but surprisingly they're more
closely related to whales than they are
to elephants
male hippos measure about 3.5 meters
long and 1.5 meters tall and they can
weigh up to 3
200 kilograms
that's as heavy as three small cars and
even at such an enormous size they're
pretty fast running at speeds of up to
40 kilometers per hour
these big animals also have big bites
do you know that a hippopotamus can open
its mouth 180 degrees
their giant pink moths are filled with
huge ivory tusks that can grow as big as
51 centimeters
you'd think that with mouths and teeth
that big they'd be man-eaters
but they're herbivores feeding mostly on
grass
so if all they eat is grass why do they
need those huge tusks and 180 degree
mouths
to fight other hippos of course
hippos are extremely aggressive and
territorial which makes them dangerous
to humans
many hippo attacks and human deaths are
caused by people entering hippos
territories hunting them or otherwise
annoying them well look at this little
fella
hello there and while they won't eat you
they will take you out especially if you
aggravate them
so if you haven't figured it out already
it's best to steer clear of hippos
unfortunately the notorious colombian
drug lord pablo escobar did not heed
this advice
he famously kept hippos giraffes
elephants and other exotic animals on
his estate in northwestern colombia
when he was killed in 1993 the colombian
government seized all his assets
most of his animals were transferred to
zoos and aquariums but his four hippos
got into colombia's waterways and
multiplied
good job pablo between 40 and 60 of
their descendants currently live in
colombia and they occasionally trample
crops and charge at humans
even worse the hippos are contaminating
colombia's waterways with their toxic
feces
their pope creates algae blooms that
reduce the oxygen available to fish and
are threatening many native species
and although hippos are extremely
dangerous to humans we are much more
deadly to them
hippos are a threatened species they
used to live throughout all of
sub-saharan africa but now they are
largely confined to protected areas in
east african countries
and hundreds of hippos are shot each
year to minimize human wildlife
conflicts despite the fact that ditches
or low fences easily deter them
humans also kill them for their fat and
their ivory tusks which are in high
demand
even though they're big and mean we
don't want hippos to become extinct
and if you want to meet one in person
you can visit the cincinnati zoo and
safely say hello to fiona hello fiona
opening their mouths 180 degrees and
taking toxic dumps is what hippos do and
that's what makes them crazy creatures